Salut les petits potes, aujourd'hui on s'attaque à piéger l'hôte d'un AirBnb.
Nous avons pris une chambre pour un soir en précisant qu’on serait deux à y dormir mais seulement un seul d’entre nous va vraiment y dormir.
L’hôte va-t'il s’en rendre compte?
Team Foufou !
Les mecs vous êtes bien en position ?
Oui, l’hôte est parti il y a maintenant 10 minutes.
Il revient demain matin à 10h.
Ce qui nous laisse un peu moins de 16h pour mettre en place le piège.
C’est parti !
Ok Jeff, rejoins-moi dans le van !
Essaie de pas trop ronfler mec, t’es filmé !
Ok les amis, il est 4h05 du matin. Dustin dort comme un bébé.
Pour l’instant tout se passe comme prévu…
Plus que 6 heures d’attente, et nous serons si le piège a fonctionné.
Après une nuit de sommeil, Jeff rejoint enfin Dustin.
Alors bien dormi dans le lit juste à côté du mien ?
Haha t’es con Jeff, arrête !
Faites-pas les cons !
Allez les mecs, ils ne vous reste plus qu'à ranger pour rendre l’appartement propre pour l'hôte, il faut que tout soit clean.
Yes !
Attention l’hôte est de retour.  C’est maintenant que tout va se jouer.
Ça va, bien dormi ?
Bonjour !
Bien passé ?
C'était très bien comme expérience !
Ça marche grave.
C’est nickel.
C'est parfait.
Ok.
Ça se déroule comme prévu.
C'est parfait.
On dirait presque que personne n’a dormi là.
Ne panique surtout pas !
Je vais trouver quelque chose, ne paniquez-pas les mecs !
Je sèche les mecs, désolé.
Je sais, t'as qu'à dire "Comme quoi" ça marche toujours.
Oui ! Tente-ça !
Comme quoi...
Comme... Ça veut rien... D'accord, salut.
Yes !
C'est ça, c'est bien.
Merci beaucoup !
C'est bien !
C'est parf.. C'est propre, merci.
Bonne journée.
Bonne journée à vous !
Les mecs vous avez assuré, il a tellement pas saisie l’entourloupe.
Hé ouais, tu croyais quoi ? T’as affaire à des champions.
Des champions du dodo ouais !
Et c’est une mission accomplie pour la team foufou !
Encore une fois, tout le monde n’y a vu que du feu !
Quoi ?!
En fait le truc c'est qu'il y en a qu'un qui a dormi dans l'appartement ?
Et alors quoi ?
Vous... Vous m'avez eu...
Oui. Oh lalala...
Oh la la la la...